hello everyone this is viewers choice
everyone's favorite I'm Grandmaster
Dennis Bosch
and today we're going to look at some
awesome games all right let's start with
this one
hi first of all thanks for giving us
viewers the opportunity for submitting
our games sure you're welcome
could you take a look at the attached
game which I played the black pieces
thank you them Sehgal I hope I said it
correctly alright so he for d6 d4 d5
he takes d5 I'm not a fan of the
exchange French with a third color I
think you should never do this even when
you want to if you really want to do it
just don't do it
so anyways you should play Knight c3
Knight d2 or anything just don't take on
d5 it's not helping your game and you
will see why so he takes d5 Knight f3
Bishop d6 now even in the exchange
variation of the French you can be
ambitious could play c4 for example
trying to challenge this pawn on d5 and
attacking it with a C pawn Knight of 6
Knight c3 and actually you get a very
interesting game yes you can get an
isolated pawn but you will get a
monstrous Bishop that will just hit on
this f7 pawn also in the future maybe
annoyed that King on g8 so it's castles
my g2 etc but this is an interesting
variation Knight f3 you're kind of
setting yourself up for a not very good
variation with white Bishop d6 but if
you must do it don't do it with Bishop
e2 play Bishop d3 instead but
many grandmasters know this is basically
just a draw night up six castle castle
Bishop g5 Bishop g4 and black only needs
to find one trick here just to copycat
and that's not too hard
so it's basically equal sometimes there
are some little tricks but it's
basically equal so it's not big deal so
anyways Bishop b2 is not good because
it's too passive and that is the main
reason I don't think anyone should play
the exchange variation because you're
trying to draw too hard you're white you
don't have to try too hard to draw try
to play a good game fight and then
you'll achieve the draw if you need it
if you play well you don't have to force
it look white is already a little
passive she's not good Knight of 6
castle should be 586 ship h4 ship f5 I
already like the way black plays here
because white is trying to kind of you
know be solid but he says okay I'll do
exactly the opposite things you do which
is a good tactic when you're facing the
exchange variation actually sometimes I
have to go back for that they would even
dare play c5 the same idea that I showed
for white the tempo down just to have an
interesting game it's not it doesn't
really mean that black will be worse
it means it's going to be a bit more
lively than in this case but even in
this case black shows how to play this
line puts the bishops on d6 and f5 which
is totally the opposite of the white
play which is aged for an e2 Knight c3
Knight c3 is not a good move because
that night will have no future on c3
what else could be
play if we're trying to play well for
white here yes night bd2 is an auction
it's good what else what else could we
play which makes sense in this position
yeah yes III just making sure this pawn
is protected but that actually it's kind
of you can't mix up the orders you can
still go 92 now you might even have like
tricky ideas of Queen b3 as I remember
this position actually karana played
this against Anand and he came up with a
plan like this it's a little risky
because this g5 pawn can G 586 pawn can
become a little weak Bishop g3 and
Knight e4 and takes and even though
blacks position is weakened a little bit
but look in the long term white will
face a pawn storm on the Kings side so
it's already nothing sorts of equal it's
a fighting game and this is actually
what Bobby did against Anand and one a
very interesting game so yeah definitely
see through an idea - should have been
preferred still so Knight c3 c6
now the main problem is this Knight has
no future so white plays Knight d5 but
I'm still not that happy with that move
as you can see that all the white moves
are built a little bit scattered there's
no consistency between the plans one of
the times he plays on the Kings side
then plays a little bit on the Queen
side and this Bishop on e2 is too
passive
instead of Knight e5 how could we
improve the position for white
yes rookie one bringing the rook into
the game that's a good idea or what else
how can we get rid of our bad pieces yes
Bishop d3 just as simple you have a bad
piece exchange it off takes Queen takes
and this is just fine for white ninety
seven and actually here white has a very
nice plan it does nothing it's still
dead equal but it's a nice plan to
remember what can y do here
again think about which piece looks the
most awkward and why it's camp try to
improve it yes Daddy to where you're
heading to to g3 although be very of
ideas of g5 before they just capture
your bishop that will be painful I mean
you have Knight f5 that's true but if I
play Queen c7 now now g3 would be
suicidal because of g5 and you can try
to gamble but why would you want to
gamble so you could go Bishop g3 and
then it's boring okay so there's one
more idea here that is kind of edgy
probably not even that good but you
could even do 91 the same plan as you've
been mentioning is like t3 Knight f5 Oh
b6 is not good but like Queen c7 93 and
now you actually have space for your
Bishop on g3 this is actually rarely
done with white this 91-93 plan but it's
not that bad sometimes in the petrov or
in the russian defense black does play
the same way but first playing like 9 f8
and 998 anyways back to the game 95 97
which is fine takes takes Queen d2 rook
e8 and finally Bishop d3 I like this
move Bishop e7 group a1 and even in the
most Anoush aspersions where you think
that oh I could be safe there's no way I
can mess it up it's possible to mess it
up
blacks next move is not good why is
Queen b6 not so great
yes
well if you play knight a four I can
move my queen away I don't see why is
that terrible yes yeah rook takes Bishop
if I take you back
she takes ya
and I'm not saying that white is totally
winning cuz they're still at five but
the whole landscape changed this rook I
mean this position is a bit more shaky
with this rook kind of hanging in the
air I can also repeat cuz you can't run
if you get checkmate it but if I really
want to fight and why wouldn't I want to
fight I could just go nighty to and just
go the long route with Nigeria night h5
and it's certainly great for white so
even when you feel that you're in the
driver's seat you should be careful it's
easy to mess up these positions so if
we're black and we conscious that pin be
sexist that's a little dangerous how
could we prepare against that and then
maybe play Queen b6
because clearly this Queen v6 rook takes
e7 is very dangerous
yeah yeah there should be six the
simplest and that's kind of prepares
Queen b6 stuff but if you really want to
get rid of some tension let's say I'm
just waiting you can go an ID seven
takes takes and I know F four looks
scary but you always have Knight f6 now
I'm said that I would even consider this
move but that's not too good so just
let's stick with Knight f6 cuz if F five
you just put the bishop back and even
though this pawn is very active it just
does no big damage it's not a big deal
so Bishop e6 would have been a really
good move I even would love to give it
an exclamation queen bee is fixed excuse
me is adventurous ambitious but Luke
takes e7 would have been painful
so Queen e3 but this gives away the pawn
rook b1 but here black comes up with a
very nice idea try to think for yourself
and think what you would play in this
position
it's actually we have a choice here you
can take the night maybe or we can move
it to a three yes
say goodnight yeah you can
well actually you can that's what he did
and the nice thing is Bishop age seven
he has this very nice idea of night
takes eight seven takes takes this is a
rare occasion you actually get three
pieces against the Queen to be honest
with you I always felt that oh the Queen
is strong enough but usually it's not
the queen is not that strong against
these light pieces because eventually
the three pieces will coordinate and
then the Queen is just hopeless
against all of these beasts Luke takes
b7 comes Knight f6 g3 and 94 and
actually that's the main issue with
these I'm not even sure if this is great
but just to prove something this is the
problem when you have a queen then
actually you run into too many attacks
so if I would want to go to a3 you can
again attack me if I we want to go to f3
you attack me an ID - so there's just
not many places I could hide probably
Queen d3 would be better and then it
might actually get dicey for black
because both of those pieces are
attacked the other hand he played Queen
a5 and missed this idea of Bishop d8
it's just super nice because after this
this d7 Bishop is freed up and if this
Bishop arrives on b6 the game is over
because white had some chances until
these LightScribe pieces got really
active but after Bishop e6 is gonna be
over Queen a3 Bishop h3 will be one
Bishop e6 and now it's really bad
because White has background issues
already this Knight is a monster this
Bishop is a monster and what is this
Queen doing on a3 not much
Queen f3 one move threat rook f8 maybe
even Bishop e6 is better
g4 but black is so winning that he has
another trick up his sleeve and plays an
ID 2 takes Knight takes p1 g5 and even
though this position is hopeless for
white this g5 idea still deserves lots
of credit because if you're lost still
try still try to confuse your opponent
the best way to confuse your opponent is
to attack his king or her King which
takes Queen h5 Knight c3 very good night
is heading back to e4 which will be a
very safe spot for the night takes 94 h4
takes bishop takes and it's basically
totally lost here in d7 night c5 yeah
now everything is falling and obviously
this relents very soon and white design
for a good reason because this is just
totally lost
so thanks play wasn't perfect but he was
aiming to unstable eyes the position and
that's the way you should play if you're
facing the exchange variation try to
create chances it's not an immediate
draw it's just an equal position alright
see so this game was played by seminyak
Daniel and Terry Colson our very own
Terry Colson so it's playing white is a
1976 rated player and Perry is rated
1676 if I remember correctly now we will
be black because black wanders game c4
c5 this is probably one of the best
moves against the English the five move
their billions of other moves Knight f6
is fine d6 is fine there's plenty of
moves you could play against c4 but e5
is the most challenging and this
actually was played in many of the cause
and Khurana games in the world
championship match Knight c3 Knight f6
g3 knight c6 Bishop c5 and what parry
chooses is a very standard plan it says
okay you want to develop your pieces you
try to put pressure on me on the Queen
side but I'll just put a Bishop on c5
hide it somewhere here and wait for your
actions
efore hmm
is he for a good move what would be our
first thought about efore yes
yeah you're right this is not really
good because it's blocking your own
Bishop the whole concept when you're
playing the English is to have this
beautiful beautiful fianchettoed Bishop
striking down on blacks position so if
he 4 is not that good
how should white continue them yes yeah
you three they often play this way
because castles nighty to you keep the
bishop diagonal open while also you're
preparing the idea of expanding the d4
now I'm not claiming white is better but
this is still a better version of the
game the four of us played which is not
good because this Bishop is not boxed in
and compared to that bishop this Bishop
on c5 is a monster I would already
rather be black than white d6 9g to
castle castle Bishop e6 d3 Bishop g4
this Bishop g4 a good move yeah
okay why is it a good move you're saying
the bishop is not doing anything on e6
so it would be better off on g4 right
that's what you're saying mm-hmm
anyone else and then I an idea instead
of Bishop g4 or would you agree the very
dead Bishop g4 is good or the best move
yeah so it does spin the Queen can we do
something better with black yes I would
also think about Queen d7 with the idea
of Bishop h3 Bishop g4 even though it's
not a bad move feels a little bit
hesitant and you are wasting some time
although it's forgiving because it's a
closed position if this would be like an
open Sicilian dragon waiting losing to
Tempe like that would be punished
Bishop e3 Bishop b4 and actually I like
this move Bishop b4 because with Bishop
g4 move this makes good sense because
you're trying to pin everything pinning
all of black White's pieces f3 f3 is a
bit too much how else could be on pin
ourselves with white because f3 I think
is a bit weakening yeah a3 well a3 I
went to b4 with the intention of taking
or c3 yes h3 yeah
now again I could try take so it can
take here first as it takes but
eventually I'll take the b7 pawn also I
will consider the idea of Queen c2 just
getting away from these pins which makes
sense to me also maybe in the future if
I start rolling with my pawn you might
have to decide where you want to move
your bishop after we have three it's
clear that you're going to move your
bishop so it plays Bishop c8 now I'm not
a fan of Bishop c8 Bishop d7 would be a
little better obviously not Bishop e6
why not though
what's wrong with Bishop e6 yes
f4 f5 a little bit but there's a bigger
issue with this Bishop e6 move
it runs deep into 95 was that what you
wanted to say yeah the problem is you
wanna take with the night but you cannot
because you will get for it you just get
for it then don't get for it and if you
have to take with the bishop that's not
your goal you want to keep this Bishop
for later action especially that they
would go f4 here and then white would
open up the position and there are pips
they're gone so that's not good
so therefore Bishop d7 should have been
preferred Bishop c8 is the concept is
not bad but Bishop d7 is better alright
Bishop c8 95 98 it's an interesting
thought it's a little passive though a3
I don't like a3 much because it's kind
of inviting black to play the best moves
possible and sometimes when you see your
opponent kind of hesitating and not
playing the right moves you should and
you could wait around to see what do
they really want what are their true
intentions that's the problem with this
a3 move by white that it shows and it
forces the opponents to play the best
moves possible don't do that so what
should I do instead
80 that's what they played
yes f4 yeah
f4 is a good move what else can you play
yes
look see one okay now if we know what
black wants to do and that's Bishop c5
what moves would we consider them
it's clear that sooner or later black
will try to do that yes okay you can
take the bishop yeah take and as you
mentioned before d4 is an idea and
especially as the position is opening up
a little bit you're going to play f4 in
the near future these bishops will
become even more powerful with the time
passing the other idea I was kind of
trying to refer to as King age one
because when Bishop c5 is played you can
move your Bishop away if you want to
especially I like this idea of King age
one here because you're giving a free
hand to your opponent to decide what
they want to do and if you see that your
opponent is unsure of what they want to
do just give them options to mess up
that's why I would consider King age one
there's an idea
so a3 and I don't like this move Bishop
c5 before takes takes the knight f6
actually deserves a lot of credit
because there he realized that the
knight is not doing much on the eight so
that's activated and sometimes you
shouldn't be you shouldn't feel ashamed
of correcting our mistakes even if it
costs us an extra move now if it's a
sharp battle when everything hinges on a
tempo don't do it obviously you get made
it that's not a good idea but this is a
closed position we won't get checkmated
in the near future so you have time to
improve your pieces so do so Knight f6 B
597 f4 c6 another good move by Barry
preparing this idea of Queen b6 and also
hinting at maybe just undermining the
white center and this is actually kind
of
this traditional English position that
looks fancy for white but it's not as
great as it looks
cuz even if you take on e5d takes e5 I
know the idea of taking on f6 looks
juicy but you don't have enough pieces
to attack write this F 5 square is
guarded and even if you attack the f6
spawn I'll just defend it the King and
there's not gonna be a lot of drama
going on here and when you play f5 we
always dream about this position that
White's saying oh I can go g4 g5 and
slowly roll you over but if black has
enough time to strike in the center
you'll be in big trouble so that's what
Perry does place Queen b6 showing that
you're pinned my friend
okay 3c takes b5 he sees the free pawn
takes the free part and if you see your
free pawn ticket will be 157 this is
fine you could also go a6
take stakes it's just an extra pawn so
that's good
there should be 793 a6 when you're up
upon there's no need to rush into action
you can just defend your pieces and
slowly you should be able to win Queen B
396 this Knight is heading into d4 which
like the only issue I have at knight c6
that this Knight was defending vital
square d5 square when we moved the night
you remove the defender so that could
lead to trouble
Queen B 294 look F to Bishop c6 but
black gets handling this position really
well so far
because he says okay I have enough time
to post its Knight into
beautiful square and I'm not scared of
your jumps cutout because I'll just take
all of your pieces h3 rook d8 so what do
you guys think about Luke d8 is it good
is it bad would you suggest something
else yes yes I love your reasoning rook
d8 doesn't do anything and this D line
will never open up or not
in like 30 moves but after rook c8 as
you said one thing that we can predict
that the sea line will get open sometime
in the future either the way of taking
and takes and now we already have this
rook on the sea line or by the way of
Knight d5 takes let's say takes takes
and C takes now they can go eat takes
but you can just move the Queen and this
rook move was useful right so rook d8 is
in this sense not bad but a little bit
inaccurate rook the 895 Knight takes d5
and I don't like Knight takes d5 I would
prefer taking with the bishop and the
reason is I'd rather push up on here and
say I'm safe forever then thinking about
what will I do if white goes f6 now our
position is so solid that it shouldn't
be a big deal but if you can't play f6
ourselves with black why wouldn't we
want to play that so I would have
preferred Bishop takes d5 tonight thinks
the 5c takes d5 Bishop d7
a 4 and H 5 is definitely not a good
move that's not the side we should be
playing on what should we be doing here
we're black yes
f6 just to stop any counter play on the
kingside or what else f6 is the super
cautious
Petrosyan kind of move we can go
aggressive if we want to
yeah rook c8 and as we can see in closed
positions you have the time to correct
your mistakes
rook d8 was a little bit iffy you plays
a4 and you can say oh never mind I'll
play rook c8 now and would be great
h5 is actually just helping white
because that you're not going to do and
give checkmate on the Kings side in the
upcoming future so h5 is not that great
92 takes takes g6 but just fine at least
these pawns are protecting each other
but already white has some level of play
g4 h4 and to be honest I like h4 because
black realizes that oh I'm not supposed
to be playing on the Kings side so
lessee gives an effort and try to close
it up Queen d2 King g7 that's again very
good this is kind of like a standard
Sicilian play you're trying to take away
these vital squares and here white
blunders what should have I do you can
see that he plays f6 which is a bad move
how should white follow up here
rook c1 what's your idea behind Roxy one
yes well but in general we can feel that
blacks King is a little bit fishy
looking so we need to find a move around
that yet yes Queen g5 and this would be
SuperDuper lost for black and the only
reason black is lost is because he
voluntarily started weakening his King
side this would be just brilliant
without age v g6 but after these two
weakening moves its lost but it's
interesting to see that f6 which is
let's be honest one of the most natural
moves and if we're playing like quick
games and I play it really fast it's not
good and this is actually like a
Sicilian pattern and Colson finds this
engage 7 pin g5 to work h8 and the
problem is for white right now is that
he's not able to checkmate and if you're
not able to checkmate in these type of
positions you're most of the time worse
and what is worse here twin g3 rook c8
finally age for trying to attack but
it's just too slow Brooksie to just
putting pressure and using this pin yet
again okay 1b takes a 4 you see a free
pawn take the free pawn h5 Queen d4
probably Queen d4 it's a little risky
would even maybe consider g5 as well
because I don't really see how you could
come close to my pawn because I would
just take you
but anyway queen d4 still makes sense
take sakes bishop h3 and black plays a3
what else could black do here in this
position that would also make sense it's
also kind of like a Sicilian theme yeah
King f7 it was the idea behind king f7
yeah and this King is very safe because
of this bond specifically and black is
just totally winning here so a3 was
played and good or bad white need it to
play f7 and hope for the best but King
g2 is not good to take sakes
and our Perry plays the King f7 move
which is the key and that black is just
totally winning because the attack is
gone and these pawns start marching rook
a to b5 is played b5 is a normal way of
winning this position but how else could
we wrap this game up
I actually preferred the other way of
playing yes rook c8 okay that's a way
how else can we push our pawns yes
well yeah you take I take your pawn no
so the other way I would consider
playing is a five takes and a four
the reason I would do it this way
because this would limit the scope of
this rook and my plan is is just to
start pushing my beep on and you can
stop me
the problem with b5 is that it takes on
a three and can i push the a pawn
obviously not and so the main issue is
that I have like this backwards pawn
that I have to support somehow and
you're just making this technical phase
way harder for yourself rook e8 I mean
still winning and Luke 8 is a good move
but black could have just gone a 584 and
just win the for a nice move because
he's trying for tricks and when you're
losing you should try everything to
avoid losing or at least you know give
your opponent a little bit of her
headache he takes up six g5 nasty check
but luckily King g7 still works he takes
me five Bishop takes h3 takes his safety
he takes e5 did like achieve his goal
yeah he did he has all these passed
pawns ready to march and white as really
no counter play so he goes rook 876 rook
g7 b4 and this is one of those things
that many people especially young
players forget
in a rock endgame you must start pushing
your passers otherwise you might be in
trouble
takes King see 5 B 5 and also like this
one the pawn is protected with by the
King and also takes away the survival
square from the rook which is often
annoying and then it's not as not always
that easy to promote those funds if the
rook is stopping you
kingi 3 a 5 B 3 was also good but I see
nothing wrong with a 5 rooks e7 a for g6
rogue g8 hmm what's wrong g8 necessary
yeah yeah it's not necessary
what could black do instead pushed upon
so I often see these and young players
they get scared that the pawn which is
the g7 square don't be scared of that
obviously right now there's like this
kind of trick but you can just take it
Queens and I clean myself so I'm up a
rope so usually the way that they can
try to punish you is to go to f7 and go
to rook F 8 and when the rook is on f7
and trying to block you from defense now
you have to play the critical move I
mean you can clean now but if our pawn
was on a3 we still need to know that
defensive method yeah rook g8 and it's
very tough to promote that pawn 1-0 gets
to g8 so I feel rook g8 now was a little
early
g7 a3 but it's still dead winning here a
- okay 7b 3 d6
rook takes takes Queens and now it's
just hopelessly lost now I still don't
like Queen e1 check but I could just go
let's say Queen d1 and if the King comes
closer how can we finish off this game
what's the easiest way yes
b2 is good but let's notice what our
opponents wants to do he still wants his
King to climb up the stairwell and we
don't want that
yeah yes yeah Queen d6 just cutting you
off the route can't move cuz has to
defend this pawn and it's now very easy
now I'm going to start pushing my pawn
sometimes if you have the time it's a
good idea to stop all counterplay
possible and that's why I would play
Queen d6 first so he played Queen e1 g5
king f6 she was actually helping white a
little bit it doesn't matter here but in
other positions these few tempest could
mean a lot B to in e7 Biman Queens d8
takes takes green takes e4 and white
resigned
overall I still like this game by black
because a when he had the time he
improves his pieces too he was patient
enough to win the game so when he was
already winning he took the time to
bring the pieces to the open file make
sure his King was defended yes h5 and g6
was not a good idea and don't follow
that ever because you're playing against
yourself if you have a majority on the
Queen side focus there especially when
we got the chance to play f6 do so stop
all the counter play where your opponent
is trying to play and just focus on the
other side so overall I really like this
game and this
be and this was viewers choice thank you
[Music]